Aging in Hollywood is really hard you
can't do anything right I had this thing
like a few weeks ago I was getting my
hair done and I had not a stitch of
makeup on so I threw on a filter I
really gave it no thought and the
picture ended up somewhere and a bunch
of people were like Jenifer of hu is
unrecognizable she's unrecognizable and
so she's gone to filters because she
doesn't want us to know how bad she
actually looks now in her 40s this is
crazy right so then I did a bunch of
like over-the-top like crazy filters on
my Instagram and I was like all natural
no filter like trying to make fun of it
and then they came after me for that and
they were like well now she's just
defending herself and like why is she
Def and I realized I was like I can do
right and why are you focusing so much
on these who have nothing
better to do than to put you down
because because to pretend that we don't
is a lie I know